♪ ♪
>> Jedediah: ANOTHER DAY OF
CLASHES IN THE STREETS OF
VENEZUELA AFTER OPPOSITION
LEADER JUAN GUAIDO CALLED FOR AN
UPRISING AGAINST THE SOCIALIST
MULTIROLE REGIME.
YOU PROBABLY NOTICED THE
PROTESTERS WERE UNARMED AND
CAN'T REALLY FIGHT BACK AGAINST
THE GOVERNMENT.
THAT'S BECAUSE VENEZUELA BANNED
PRIVATE GUN OWNERSHIP IN 2012.
WHILE COVERING THE CAST
YESTERDAY, THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
ACCIDENTALLY SLIPPED UP AND
DEFENDED AMERICA
SECOND AMENDMENT.
WATCH.
>> HAVE TO UNDERSTAND IN
VENEZUELA, GUN OWNERSHIP IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT IS OPEN TO
EVERYBODY.
SOME OF THE MILITARY HAS THE
GUNS, THEY HAVE THE POWER.
AS LONG AS THE NICOLAS MADURO
CONTROLS THE MILITARY, HE
CONTROLS THE COUNTRY.
>> Jedediah: JESSE, QUITE A
SLIP UP THERE.
I ALWAYS WONDER WHY IT'S SO HARD
FOR PEOPLE AND MEDIA TO REALIZE
THAT WAS HAPPENING OVER THERE
COULD HAPPEN OVER HERE.
SAME THING FOR SOCIALISM, IT'S
LIKE THAT'S OVER THERE.
THAT'S HAPPENING OVER THERE.
BUT THAT IS WHAT THE FEAR IS,
THAT ULTIMATELY ONE DAY COULD
THAT HAPPEN HERE IF ALL OF OUR
RIGHTS ARE TAKEN AWAY?
>> Jesse: THE MEDIA NEVER
LOOKS TO REALITY FOR EXAMPLES.
THEY CAN SEE EVERYTHING
HAPPENING ALL OVER THE WORLD,
BOTH EMILY SAY OKAY, WHAT ABOUT
ITS IMPACT HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES, THEY NEVER TAKE
THAT TO HEART.
I THINK IT WAS ACOSTA, JIM AT
CNN WHO ACCIDENTALLY MITIGATES
FOR THE WALL WHEN HE WENT DOWN.
ONCE IN A WHILE, THESE THINGS
HAPPEN.
THIS ISN'T THEORETICAL.
ERIC SWALWELL WHO'S RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT HAS TALKED ABOUT GUN
CONFISCATION.
STACEY ABRAMS, GEORGIA DEMOCRAT,
HAS ALSO TALKED ABOUT GUN
CONFISCATION AND GOING
DOOR-TO-DOOR TO ENFORCE THE
CONFISCATION.
SO WHEN CONSERVATIVES IN THIS
COUNTRY TALK ABOUT THE
SECOND AMENDMENT AND RIGHTS THAT
NEED TO BE PROTECTED, IT'S NOT
THEORETICAL.
WE HAVE SEEN THE LAST
ADMINISTRATION USE THE IRS TO
TARGET THE TEA PARTY.
WE HAVE SEEN THE LAST
ADMINISTRATION VIOLATE ALLEGEDLY
THE PRIVACY OF TRUMP CAMPAIGN
OFFICIALS.
WE HAVE SEEN A LOT OF THEIR
GOVERNMENT USE THEIR POWER.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT EXAMPLES IN
VENEZUELA, THAT'S QUINTESSENTIAL
GOVERNMENT ABUSE OF POWER AND
NOT A PEACEFUL TRANSFER OF POWER
WHICH WE ACTUALLY DIDN'T REALLY
HAVE LAST TIME AS WELL.
>> Juan: DO YOU THINK IF THOSE
PEOPLE HAD GUNS THERE WOULD BE
ANYTHING BUT MORE CHAOS, MORE
VIOLENCE AND MORE DEATH?
>> Jesse: IT PREVENTS THE
GOVERNMENT FROM BEING THAT
EGREGIOUS --
>> Juan: LET ME ASK YOU,
NEW YORK CITY, YOU THINK IF YOU
HAVE A GUN YOU COULD STAND UP TO
THE NEW YORK CITY POLICE
DEPARTMENT MUCH LESS THE
NATIONAL GUARD OR THE MILITARY.
>> Jesse: IF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE ARMED --
>> Juan: TO THE TEETH.
>> Jesse: TO THE TEETH, WHICH
WE ARE.
>> Jedediah: YOU DON'T THINK
THE CITIZENRY HAS A RIGHT TO --
THEY ARE FACED WITH A TERRIFIC
LEADER.
THEY ARE PROTESTING THAT THEY
ARE POWERLESS.
>> Juan: THEY ARE NOT
POWERLESS.
>> Jedediah: THEY ARE BEING
RUN OVER BY MILITARY TANKS
BECAUSE THE MILITARY IS MOSTLY
SIDING WITH MADURO AND THE REST
OF THE POPULATION THAT ARE
FIGHTING FOR THEIR RIGHTS, THEY
ARE UNARMED.
>> Juan: THIS IS A FANTASY.
FIRST OF ALL, IT'S AN APPLES AND
ORANGES COMPARISON BETWEEN THE
U.S. AND ANOTHER COUNTRY.
THERE IS NO REALITY TO THE IDEA
THAT IF SOME PEOPLE HAD GUNS,
AUTOMATIC WEAPONS, THEY COULD
STAND UP TO THE MILITARY.
NO.
THAT'S AN INVITATION TO MORE
DEATH AND CHAOS.
IT'S A REACH BY PEOPLE TRYING TO
MAKE THE ARGUMENT FOR GUNS FOR
EVERYONE.
IN.
>> Greg: THE
ANTI-SECOND AMENDMENT ACTIVISTS
OFTEN DISMISS THE ARGUMENT THAT
LAWFUL GUN OWNERSHIP PREVENTS --
IS AN ORGANIC DEFENSE AGAINST
TYRANNY.
THAT IS LONG AS WE HAVE THE
SECOND AMENDMENT, WE HAVE GUNS,
BUT THERE'S PROBABLY NEVER GOING
TO BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR A
GOVERNMENT TO TURN TYRANNICAL OR
SOCIALIST OR FASCIST IN THE
UNITED STATES.
SOMEONE ARGUE TRUMP IS ALREADY
THERE BUT I GOTCHA.
THE MEDIA MAKES THE CASE FOR
EVERYTHING THEY ARE AGAINST.
TRUMP IS A   A GREAT EXAMPLE.
I THINK THEY ELECTED TRUMP BY
MAKING ARGUMENT AGAINST HIM.
WHY IS IT ONLY SOCIALIST
COUNTRIES WANT TO TAKE AWAY YOUR
GUNS?
THEY KNOW ULTIMATELY THEIR
IDEOLOGY CAN ONLY BE COERCED.
GUNS MAKE THAT CAUTION
IMPOSSIBLE.
ONCE THE GUNS ARE IN THE HANDS
OF THE POPULATION YOU CAN NO
LONGER CONTROL THE POPULATION.
>> Dana: I WAS GOING TO MAKE
THE SAME ARGUMENT BUT THE
REVERSE WHICH IS THE BEST WAY TO
PREVENT THIS FROM EVER HAPPENING
HERE IS TO CONTINUE TO HAVE A
FREE AND FAIR COUNTRY THAT
RESPECTS THE RULE OF LAW.
>> Jedediah: ABSOLUTELY.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT WHEN
THE WEAPONS CONFISCATION PLAN